hey everybody and welcome to an out of
this world wild ride with stevo we've
got one of the founding members of
blink182
tom delong who happens to be an expert
on ufos and aliens and maybe in some
trouble with the government it's
wild and he might
be about to scare you a little bit
talking about aliens how real they are
the ufos
maybe there's threats that you can't
even see actually you know what there
are definitely threats that you can't
even see i don't know if they're aliens
but there are definitely people creeping
into your phone creeping into the
computer hopping on the wi-fi stealing
your information and your money
not cool that's why i use nord vpn
because i don't need people stealing my
information and my money that's what
nordvpn does it's called virtual private
network and it just makes it so that
nobody
even knows where you are and not only
does that make you safer from cyber
crime but
this is the best part it you can just be
anywhere in the world that you choose
right now i'm at home in los angeles
right if i wanted to uh use my nordvpn
to
just be in england because
in my opinion british people make way
better television maybe i want to watch
all the cool shows in
british netflix no problem and guess
what i'm about to leave my house
go to the airport and fly to england and
that's where i'm going to be this
weekend when the ufc fights are on but
do you think i'm going to let the
the out of
of uh range whatever you know not in the
boundaries where you can watch no
because i'm gonna be in england and i'm
gonna actually be in america watching
the fights because i got nordvpn it's
the best the greatest and man they're
gonna hook you up they've got a deal for
you if you go to nordvpn.com
stevo or just use the promo code stevo
you get a huge discount on your plan
plus they'll throw in an extra month
totally for free and it's risk-free with
the 30-day money-back guarantee but
i don't know how you couldn't be more
than satisfied to know that you are
protected from cyber crime enjoying
awesome content from all over the world
and you're getting a huge deal for it so
go to nordvpn.com
stevo or use the promo code stevo to
jump on this deal because man
i don't want you getting
robbed and i want you to support the
podcast so get on over to nordvpn.com
and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen tom delong
hi
hello dude this is my co-host scott
randolph what's up scott greetings yeah
thanks for doing this man we've uh
just worked our way into
your day of recording yeah yep you uh i
[ __ ] walk outside and there's like a
van no actually what really happened let
me actually tell you the real story
i walked into the kitchen
and the dog is sitting there
it's like perfect like a [ __ ] canine
from the fbi and i found out that one of
the groms gave him some bacon yeah so i
get it and i come out and here's the van
you got air conditioning you let me
choose the color i'm like this is like
the easiest interview ever you got an
awesome dog and uh and it's cool in here
and you know you guys just quality
people you know well thanks man i
appreciate it
so what is it that you're recording i'm
recording uh guitars and i'm doing um
working on a live album
uh for angels and airwaves right now
nice yeah good [ __ ] man so we're about
the same age dude i was born in 74.
you are but you're so much more mature
than me you know that extra year you got
on me is like super like just life
experience you know
i i mean who knows man
it's good stuff um
i had an experience you know i was on
cameo for uh i think it was
like i was on cameo for a minute there
and i had like uh the one request that
came from uh
like a legit thing was blink182
yeah what like what request in what way
what they requested for you to do a
cameo for them to promote some i forget
i figured it was if it was a
music project uh you know that's right
that's right like record labels are
going to cameo girl we need to get some
like [ __ ] some quality people to talk
about that yeah like restaurants are
getting snoop to like promote for their
business you know it's like snoop's like
it's usually 50k but on cameo it's like
1500 bucks it's a workaround i know it's
weird and um i was so happy to do it and
i recorded this video saying that in
year 2000 before jackass came out and
while i was working as a circus clown in
a flea market
everyone starts out things this way
i was at a blink 182 concert in miami i
believe it was american airlines arena
and i started out at the top of the
arena and walked down all the stairs
just in one of the aisles like on my
hands in a handsome that's funny
that one uh
i was just really proud of that i also
once got kicked out of a kiss concert
for for breathing fire in the audience
uh because they don't like fire yes
they've never used it they don't like it
well i wasn't the band wasn't mad at it
well actually maybe the band was mad
because i blew a bigger fireball than
gene simmons that's what i'm saying it's
really about egos here
yeah that's funny i'm surprised you guys
never crossed paths in the early 2000s
we did i i met you um bam and some of
the other dudes um
a few places it was always like in a
crowd backstage or at like a snowboard
event or a skate event or some [ __ ] um
but we did but it's not like we ever
hung
um but the thing that's funny is like
like growing up a skateboarder that was
like my life right and um
my friends were exact blink came out of
a group of skateboarders that was
exactly like you and all your buds like
so
it's funny when you meet when i met them
or we cross paths or whatever it's
really the same culture it's different
than skateboarding now in many ways
where you know now you got a helmet and
a skate park that's like where like we'd
[ __ ] jump people's fences when their
pool wasn't full yet you know that's the
only pool you got you know until they
catch it so but so the culture back
there was super unifying and like the
warp tour and all that [ __ ] so like um
whenever we would hang with anybody
affiliated with you and your friend
groups and all the jackass [ __ ] like it
was very like oh yeah these are like my
neighbors you know these dudes i skate
with every day and i try to explain that
to people
about that about growing up in
skateboarding that way like you know
that's what that's where bling came from
except we were also kind of involved in
surf too i wasn't into surfing but
taylor steele and all that [ __ ] um
they had a really strong culture too but
that's the they're like but they're like
the colgate smile like good looking
surfers and [ __ ] like skateboarders were
all looking dirty and slamming on the
concrete it's a little bit different you
know yeah
um when uh
like early 2000s when we would have met
like how loaded would you have been
on drugs or what yeah or money
no no yeah i mean i mean like
how rich were you i didn't know it's
like such a great answer that was a good
question
but uh you know i don't know well back
then like
i was always stoner um
i had a lot of fun with pills narcotics
for a long time and that almost [ __ ]
killed me so i think i got out of that
alcohol was i used to tell you i don't
drink because i don't like alcohol well
i drink when i play shows well i play
shows 10 months out of the year yeah i
was like [ __ ] you know like
i was like [ __ ] i'm like you know you
walk around with like no i don't drink
that much all right you know but i'm
like [ __ ] i kind of i've had my time you
know and uh i'm just thankful that i got
out of it decently clean you know but
i'm
yeah it's hard like you know it's like
it's [ __ ] hard to be young traveling
around with a job where you don't really
have a boss you know right and you're
kind of like rewarded for being a
[ __ ]
you know and you work one hour a day
and you could choose if you even want to
do that you know
right yeah yeah it's so funny like uh i
went through the airport with somebody
and uh
they're like oh i got weed on me and i'm
like you have weed on you through the
airport like yeah you can't do that and
it's like you guys grew up in the
generation where you were touring where
you couldn't even like smuggle dude weed
through the airports one time because we
would get these [ __ ] um
we would get these like private like
shuttles at airports so kids wouldn't
bother us yeah and so i remember this
one time i had a bunch of weed in my
suitcase
and because you know whatever they don't
i could see them checking my pockets and
my carry-on but the shuttle group with
just our band took us into a private
office and said okay they're going to
bring security and just check your
luggage here i was like
okay well i wonder if they're going to
go in my suitcase i didn't i thought it
would just run through an x-ray not a
big deal well um there's two dudes and
while look one guy's looking at one one
guy's looking at the other i just kind
of opened mine up and i just [ __ ] uh
i shuffle something and then the guy
gets up and leaves the other person goes
hey hey and i go what because he went to
go get more security because i saw all
this [ __ ] pot in my bag and i was
like [ __ ] so i just grabbed it and i ran
out of that room and i took off down the
terminal to a bathroom and i [ __ ]
threw it all through it all the way i
come back and there's three of the big
[ __ ] security dude
authority dudes in there and um they
don't find it i think hey what's going
on yeah they obviously didn't find
anything so i'm like okay maybe i'm cool
maybe i'm cool and then i get in the car
they lock everything up and i get in the
car and now they're driving us on the
tarmac to the airplane just to skip the
gate and everything and i'm like we're
cool we're cool and then right when we
get to the point right before we get to
the plane a cop car was right behind us
i'm a tarmac and i was like
[ __ ] i hope they're not here for me like
i don't know what they're here for you
know but then all of a sudden like we
get on the plane and like cockroaches
parks and they come on and then they're
on the plane looking i'm like [ __ ] i
hope they're not here for me still you
know and that's all cool and that didn't
happen so then we're flying and then
right when we land my security guard um
goes um
he goes you just go straight to the van
don't get your luggage you know
and so i did that and turns out they put
these stickers i don't know existed on
my luggage it says the letters d e which
means drug enforcement
so they just if they think there's
something there they stick it and they
call ahead and so if you see cops at a
baggage claim waiting around they might
be looking for that sticker they'll grab
that luggage it's and so like and that
happened so my bag came out with drug
enforcement stickers on it and my
security guard my my bodyguard did just
rip the stickers off and took it because
he knew what to look for
um so it's kind of [ __ ] what a great
story that was yeah well it's just like
really enjoyable but you know what's
stupid about it it's [ __ ] pot it's
like dude this isn't like
i mean dude this is like this literally
the one thing that doesn't kill you and
doesn't addict you and doesn't really
[ __ ] you up other than you eat a little
bit and say some dick jokes but like
it's so [ __ ] like the whole thing
around weed and yeah you know
did you have any cool places where you
used to try to smuggle drugs and
different things like usually
no like
it's i was always i was never pulling
that [ __ ] like international like the
last thing you want to do is go to jail
and [ __ ] peru or something not that
we ever toured peru but you found a dog
in prayer which is awesome um but so i
never did that um you just try and find
things there but i wasn't really into
i wasn't that gnarly about it like back
then like now i kind of go if i go on
tour like i would how do i get we
it's so boring i don't know what i'm
gonna do you know but um back then i was
like i i just wasn't that crazy about it
or i had prescription pills that was
like my thing i broke my back like i had
like
multiple herniated discs and they broke
in pieces tangled in my sciatic i was
like on a cane for like a year how did
you break your back well just long time
playing guitar hunched over and launch
ramps remember launchers are so big when
were younger yeah what the [ __ ] were we
thinking off in a slam like eight feet
bam over and over again and then we're
like maybe that wasn't the smartest way
to do it but did you ever like ollie off
the lawn champion was you're an early
grabber i was an early grabber because i
just never had the the i just never had
the chops to do me either transitions
like oh you made me feel better okay
good yeah meet me either i i i i had a
little phase of ollying off them and it
was very brief remember notice oh my god
not
it it breaks my heart that he doesn't
follow me back on instagram
i have a natas board that i made into a
uh
like where the wheel my girl made it for
me the wheels are light bulbs it's on
the wall so it's a lamp that's sick it's
the dude it's got trucks and the wheels
are like there was like a whole time
frame and skateboarding was like no it's
cop it's not it's guys the raddest name
he's the raddest
he's just the raddest guy there ever was
i mean dude he would do [ __ ] but he
would ollie off these launch ramps and
embankments and he's like 18 feet in the
air and you're like whoa right when he
board slid the
the crossbar on the jeep oh dude you
know who else is rad like him is jeremy
klein jeremy's a friend of mine and i've
talked to him in years but i used to
scare them all time and jeremy was like
that like well here's like a beautiful
ledge to skate and he's like but look at
that little bump over there with weeds
on it and a rock and like trash and he
goes to that one time i slammed so hard
that i thought i was dying right and he
comes right past me and i'm in the worst
pain still i haven't like come out of it
yet i'm like literally think i'm dying
and all he says is that she get for
ollying because he spent the whole day
doing slappies
just [ __ ] slappies and because i all
laid and ate [ __ ] like so rad man like
he was in
the rubbish heap video which i remember
that i don't remember the video but i
remember that name the rubbish heap
video was spike jones's first ever video
project jones it was a video for world
industries that jeremy klein was in it
jeremy cline was in the end and
everything um yeah i love that we have
the skateboarding in common yeah yeah
did you ever did you ever do like uh an
early grab 360 off a launcher [ __ ] no
dude i'm like straight up melancholy's
methods and [ __ ] maybe try a judo back
in the day
you know like i remember the day i was
skating um this place and like this dude
shows up with pitch black hair punk rock
dickies and [ __ ] and he's doing 360
[ __ ] varial flips or something to
disaster slides and it was hensley
wow and i was like floor because this is
that at that moment
he is the guy for street you know
he was yeah and i remember like going
i don't know if my [ __ ] judo is good
enough
you know but i couldn't flip the ball i
mean now these groms are like [ __ ]
360 foot they stand in a parking lot and
do it for months until they can do it
and i was like i couldn't i can't do
that like it's so it's so insane i don't
know how a kid could be introduced to
skateboarding for the first time see
what the pros are doing and be like oh
dude i'm gonna get into this it's so
gnarly i mean it's so gnarly that people
are like well kickflip is just like the
beginning of what i'm doing in the air
right it's just like the first of three
things i'm doing it's just but the
flipping stuff was just taking off when
i was skateboarding because i really
stopped skating when i got it when i got
out of high school and i started touring
and i was like i can't break my wrists
did you graduate high school 93 93 yeah
yeah so i had to like i just couldn't do
crazy [ __ ] i was always like going on
tour so that's crazy that that blink was
formed when you were still in high
school 16. yeah that's why uh that's why
the dick jokes were just so great you
know like because we were just right in
the middle of where they should have
been great and so now
you've got uh are you more in
like the the tv film stuff than music
kind of both um but yeah i i'm pretty
heavily into the film stuff um i put out
a movie called monsters of california i
made a movie called monsters california
we launched the teaser trailer for it a
few weeks ago um the whole thing that'll
come out this year um but that's like
this rad indie um story about three
skateboarders but our kind you know like
just
actual like [ __ ] dirty dudes and it
was funny which was funny because every
time i was talking to people in
hollywood about this like
like when i was getting it developed and
setting it up i was always just like
okay you know when when i say
skateboarding i was like it's not what
you think because i know what you're
thinking you see kids with helmets
running around all perfect like a skate
park i'm all i go it's like and i would
always go back oh it's like stevo and
bam and the guy i mean that's my friends
okay that's who i grew up with just
picture those guys as my best friends
you know that's who's in this movie you
know and i you can't cat you can cast
skateboarders and stuff but um for me we
did like we i found three dudes they're
like you know like
17 18 years old is what they play and um
but they're just edgy just boys you know
and it's cool because i
until mid 90s when jonah hill did mid
90s i was like i've never seen anything
where they captured skateboarding in the
way i knew it right and that really
reminded me of like the hot summer days
like getting into trouble and and
everyone's really rough around the edges
you know so monsters california as these
three skateboarders get all [ __ ] up
mixed in with all this paranormal stuff
government stuff and all those ufo stuff
and um and then that kind of was the
beginning of setting up like a whole
bunch of other films that i'm doing
these are big science fiction things um
yeah i saw like uh was it like a
deadline article about like you're
you've got like a series based on your
book about ufos and then now there's
like a subsequent series to that yeah so
legendary picked up um my books called
secret machines it's like these 700 page
novels that are about ufos uh story
about ufos but it's all governments all
like military industrial complex think
like area 51 cia department of defense
um and then their counterparts in other
countries and intermixed with that is
some of the things flying around are are
totally different entirely you know um
and so that's it's a big deal because
this is the this is the true story of
ufos of what's been going on with our
government and everything else so
i think tom delong might be out of his
mind because the guys just like trying
to get himself in trouble with the
government and that's crazy you could
say that he's living on the razor's edge
and when it comes to my razor's edge i
only go to one company it's called
harry's
they make the best
and no frills classy good looking
shaving products that are so affordable
and i gotta say i am embarrassed of all
the years that i used those vibrating
gimmicky like super overcharging
dumb
razors because harry's just it's
everything i need and if you're a first
time harry's user
man are they going to hook you up you go
to harrys.com
and you get the starter kit which is the
weighted ergonomic handle the five blade
razor you got the the travel case which
protects the razor and you've got the
faming foaming shave gel it's everything
that you need it's a 13 value and
they're gonna give it to you for only
three dollars
man once you try hairs you're never
going to go back to all that gimmicky
nonsense that everybody's paying so much
money for it that they just don't need
harry's is everything you need and i
love it and i love you and i know you
love the podcast so support the podcast
by getting this great deal on your
starter kit by going to harry's dot com
slash stevo
yeah dude now let's secure about this
crazy governments
i think that
that there's two things that really
strike me as crazy about the the
developments with ufos number one
it's crazy that the government
uh is all of a sudden just sort of
saying yeah the ufos are real you know
there's like you know all this
like the government acknowledged you
know we did that i did that that's why
they're doing that
but what's even i would say i sound like
a dick when i say that but i'm like
that's why i there's a whole story here
but keep going it's it's crazy to me
that the the government's acknowledging
ufos are very real and it's even crazier
that that news comes out and like
everyone's like oh yeah they're all
yeah but interest rates are gnarly and
like [ __ ] covet you're like
what the [ __ ] like that's how a lot of
us so what happened was is that book
secret machines i i wrote that with an
author and i started my company to the
stars and we're going to publish a book
and then when i put it in there because
i started ufos like 20 years and i was
like i figured out what's going on not
just like the [ __ ] you read or thing
like i figured out what's like what's
going on and i was like
[ __ ] if i put this out there and open my
big mouth i might get in a lot of
trouble so i should probably go ask for
some permission so i spent like a long
time working my way in and then i got
into a group of
people and
and
they brought me in and um i was given
all the permission so then i come out
with a book and i go on national radio
and all this [ __ ] well apparently that
group didn't really talk to another
group of some other three letter places
and those other places got really
[ __ ] pissed because uh here's this
[ __ ] rockstar kid like
like telling the biggest national
security secrets that we got period and
so they
came and they were like
we need to know who the [ __ ] you are and
who the [ __ ] you're talking to and all
this crazy like ed snowden type [ __ ] and
i was like hold on and i had to explain
that like all this really classified
crazy [ __ ] i figured that out on my own
i don't have anyone passing me like
dude i'm sorry man i was tripping balls
sorry i was stoned one night and i just
kind of [ __ ] did a puzzle and i was
like whoopsie you know so what happened
then was
um
the you know hillary clinton was running
for presidency against uh i guess it was
against trump and er and john podesta
was her campaign manager okay at the
time he was also senior adviser to obama
so i was holding conversations with
podesta to get to obama and i had
two multi-star generals from space
command and the head of lockheed martin
skunk works that skunk works built area
51 um their elite engineering division i
had them all on this like [ __ ] emails
and we're setting up these conference
calls and stuff well
hillary clinton's campaign got hacked by
the russians wikileaks and it outed all
this [ __ ] about podesta and her
and what happened with that was when
all these news journalists were pouring
through wikileaks to see what spilled
from hillary's campaign they found these
[ __ ] emails with me and podesta
talking to these generals about ufos
so wall street journal threw that onto
the wall street journal and then i was
like
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] and i'm like out there
like [ __ ] erasing computers and doing
all this different i didn't know what to
do um and at that time all these other
government people that came out
let me ask you why would that be a
problem for you if i mean there's no
there's nothing wrong with exchanging
emails with uh that wasn't the issue the
more of the issue was like
the more of the issue their insecurity
just all these guys are
holding the secrets of the universe
and it's a much
what would happen in conversations is i
just knew things so i would say it
they might not say something back but
i'm kind of thinking that any of those
conversations should not be [ __ ]
poured over by anybody okay that wants
to just come in and just like make a
name for themselves at the bureau you
know
so i'm just like tripping like [ __ ]
and then i could see that yeah so
what happened though is it gave me all
this credibility because then all of a
sudden all these other people in the
government knew that i was like hanging
around with some big boys so they all
came out and said there's a better way
to do what you're doing and then that's
when my company was a lot just me it
became something bigger and so
the company
came out to the public founded by myself
one of the heads of the cia and the head
physicist for the ufo program and then i
hired the program director the guy that
ran the ufo program and then i brought
on another like eight people from the
dod and the cia so they're all part of
my company and the first thing we did
was take those videos to the new york
times and out the program and then we
went and spent two years briefing all
the committees in the senate and
congress and the director the office of
the director of national intelligence so
now you're seeing hearings the dod
admitted ufo's real the navy admit
that's all us the hearings at congress
and the ufo the uap uh task force that's
all that we started all of that and it
all started with me just being a little
punk rock kid just going i'm gonna
[ __ ] do this not really knowing what
i was playing with you know so
i mean it's super impressive and and i
love how
well you communicate too your your
ability to tell stories is is really
well thank you he's a highly evolved
being i'm just i'm just a very spiritual
dude man it did i love it um
can you help us understand what what's
the
significance of ufos like they're not
coming from
well i should say this way the
significance of ufos is is multiple
parts but
number one it's not what you think it is
it's not coming from other planets the
evidence doesn't suggest that
inter-dimensional yes and the reason is
because time is
time is parallel it's not linear or it's
not like we start here and go forward in
time
time is side by side which means
everything in the past and the future is
existing in this moment but within
different frequencies
so
a civilization that's at the end of
their technological cycle
could build a submarine that changes its
voltage and materializes in that same
location just into our timeline and then
[ __ ] it's crazy
that was well articulated i like that
have you ever had any like glitches in
the matrix where like like yes time sped
up for you or like i've had that a
couple times weird things so um
like this yeah yeah but when it was when
i got more into this so so there's a
consciousness aspect to this like you
have to think of like um
consciousness is like it's like the mind
of god you know it's not a dude in a
toga with a crown of thorns making
jupiter you know it's like everything
you see is one band of frequencies the
highest frequency is light unified mind
the lowest frequency would be blackness
absent absent absence of love absence of
whatever and in physical matter
somewhere right in the middle right so
you have the ability to tune up higher
or tune down lower and behavior and all
these things in time and it all [ __ ]
comes together but what it means also is
that your brain
is what's called um a transducer you're
an antenna consciousness that's what i
was saying to uh
duncan trussell yeah duncan trussell
so you create matter
and when you think something it creates
it it's and you are not you're not
reactionary to your environment you're
actually proactive and you just don't
know it so it really matters what you
choose to see and feel because that's
literally what's being created for you
and people don't know this [ __ ] so when
you're like really into some crazy [ __ ]
the universe will start creating things
and we just think it's paranormal like
um for example at ucla they were
studying poltergeist events and they
found out that you could see a book move
on the shelf and it scares you but if
you see a book move on the shelf and it
scares the [ __ ] out of you that book
will then fly off the shelf and try and
hit you so the more scared you get the
more [ __ ] starts happening and they
didn't know why well the reason is is
you're a transducer of your environment
you're an antenna plugging into all
these frequencies and once you go oh
that book is moving it'll move
you know so it's [ __ ] crazy it's like
it's our universe it's just not what we
think it is and and the whole thing with
ufos is that they're [ __ ] around with
us because of that you know is it not
like i
would not
think of ufo
as
like a vehicle right which aliens are
gonna
travel in
yeah should we not should we not be
using the term aliens yeah alien is hard
only because it's like
that that makes us think it's coming
from mars or some [ __ ] or a different
planet these are more like entities
these are more like a lot of them are um
there's a lot there's like clones that
are like just [ __ ] like you think we
made dolly the sheep and we think that
we're like you think that's all we've
done in the 60s we cloned a sheep
we might be a little bit more advanced
than that so what is something else
that's super advanced
doing ai and creating things that can
fly around and tamper well are they
little program bots well where's like
the mainframe well maybe the ship is
alive in a mainframe biological organism
but it's metal and whatever but there's
an intelligence to it because it's so
advanced okay so so the theory that they
they started showing up at the time we
did nuclear
weapons they're not here to protect us
they're because that would be
like it's not interdimensional that'd be
from like outer space no they're
probably not three-dimensional because
the one thing we found out is that the
emp wave from a nuclear blast kind of
travels through multiple dimensions
so it's like that that energy is [ __ ]
up whatever's in that location and maybe
those people like what the [ __ ] was that
let's materialize into that other
timeline and get those [ __ ] to
stop but the reality is too is ufos have
been around forever like you're talking
biblical you're talking religions you're
talking about the pyramids the pyramids
you're talking the star of bethlehem is
not a star the sun is big the star
bethlehem is like a little ball of light
that three dudes on horses followed for
days and it hovered over a manger so
think about that what is that ezekiel's
wheels you know fatima and portugal all
these religious events are always the
same thing and you got to then go well
what are they doing what is happening
from that well we start cults we go
crazy we create different religions we
have different belief systems we get
really scared because they prophesize
the end of the world they tell you that
if you do something wrong
you're going to burn in hell for
eternity but if you listen to what that
voice is in your head that's god so do
that and then someone hears a burning
bush and they go and start a religion
you know it's like holograms and
technologies and and you in
making people not be together you know
making us think that there's a dude
like allah or jesus that created the
universe versus
source intelligence such as like your
bandwidth your fiber optic cable just to
like consciousness which is like the one
power that powers the atom that's that
permeates everything and we're all from
it but as long as we think it's a dude
and that group over there thinks it's a
different dude we're gonna hate each
other and we don't really evolve and we
don't really grow spiritually you know
i'm sure you've heard the story
i went down the rabbit hole with uh you
know like
they brought people to alpha centauri to
live like 13 people yeah and serpo is
that true i mean what is that different
than like what's going on now like is
are stories like that true or i don't
buy those i i at all but i do know some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] where like
you it makes you kind of wonder about
the other stuff so
for example there i was um
there's a document that leaked
that described something coming from
another planet and then it hit like a
meteor and then it all came down and
then we retrieve these bodies in the
craft and whatever
so i i knew this document and then i was
in a meeting i can't say with who and
what it was all about but
i found out during that meeting
that that was misinformation
the part about the media and coming from
another planet
and then they leaked the document and
the whole point was for us to keep
thinking these are coming from planets
and [ __ ] um because it's a lot less
scary you know to think well they're
super far away so it's hard for them to
get here you know but the reality is is
like
the the misinformation placed in
documents that are already leaked on
purpose is to slowly inoculate us and to
be okay with things over time it's a lot
easier to go well they're not coming
from other planets they're coming from
here but you already knew about them so
it's not as scary it's not too much
thrown on you at once but the the
absurdity that comes along with this
stuff
is insane like in the sense of like
dude i've been told so many [ __ ]
stories there's like [ __ ] where things
just show up and um
and they look you know totally human and
then you turn around and it's not even
there but you're on a ship in the middle
of the atlantic and you're on an
aircraft carrier and it's like there's a
human standing there telling you to get
the [ __ ] out of the area and then you
turn around and that [ __ ] human's not
even there you know so you're kind of
going well did we go to another planet
like those things what i would say is
there is potential that something like
that happened
but i would say 70 of what's in there is
probably untrue or something i think
that there are things on other planets
but i think that what's really going on
is like space time they call it space
time is because
if you light a flashlight that light
travels for infinity so if you were just
like when we see a star they always tell
you you're seeing like you're we're
seeing what happened like 30 000 years
ago because that light just got here so
we're essentially seeing
the beginning we're seeing the same star
but we're seeing a different point in
time than where it's at but we're
looking at it and that's the idea that i
think in space
the way things stretch out with light is
the way everything exists all in one
moment so i don't know how much planet
to planet [ __ ] transportation is
going on i don't doubt it but what i do
know is the things that are
materializing here are doing it
frequency and timelines and stuff
when you said the
materialize in a different you know time
yeah like and the describing the
parallel timelines
that uh was so digestible
i was able to to really like
look at that i i had a question that was
keeping me up last night
um i read this book uh was it the
pleiadians have you heard about that
yeah yeah i know yeah like i wrote it
i [ __ ] i i [ __ ] a palladian it was
gnarly
it's the gnarliest things i've ever done
um
this book uh i forget the the lady who
wrote it but she was speaking to the
pleiadians and uh there was this theory
presented in this book which i read
which was that
uh
junk dna if you've heard of this yeah
okay so scientists refer to
some
90
of our genetic makeup of our dna as junk
dna they cannot understand what the what
purpose it serves we only use
there's only they can only identify
ten percent of our dna as actually
having anything to do with us as
organisms and the theory in this book
was that
uh
that entities at one point found uh
humans to be
uh
dangerous you know uh capable of too
much uh disruption and
went in and unplugged
our dna
it's hard for me to imagine that
90
of our dna is
junk that serves no purpose that doesn't
add up to me man i think that the
universe is a little bit more
intelligent than that i think our
biology is a little more intelligent
than that and if there's anything i've
learned about my biology is that my
boner is way harder and way more fun
when i'm using blue chew tablets and
what are blue chew tablets well they're
delicious chewable tablets that have the
same active ingredient as both viagra
and cialis except they only cost a
fraction of the price
man
dude i had the best time when i noticed
on the packaging that it said uh take
one to two tablets i was like dude i can
take two
so yeah i'd shoot up two
and i took lux to
bone town to the boneyard yeah i parked
in the pink zone baby
she doesn't like when i say this but i
plugged into the meat socket and we both
had the best time ever and now if you're
thinking but what about like uh it's a
prescription i got to go to the doctor
yup except you don't have to do that in
person at some awkward doctor's office
hell no you go to bluechew.com
and you consult with one of their
medical providers online super fast
super easy and your blue chew tablets
are on the way now for the best part you
get an entire month's supply completely
for free all you gotta pay is five bucks
for shipping i'm telling you man could
they be cooler no they couldn't be
cooler so maybe
my dudes you want to have a super boner
maybe you want to get super laid
go to bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo for an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets all
you gotta pay is five bucks for shipping
hey
you can thank me later now let's talk
about dna
because the purpose the theory is that
the purpose of the junk dna ninety
percent of our dna was actually
uh
that was what made us
interdimensional beings
and so by unplugging our dna we no
longer operated
in uh
in a higher frequency or something yeah
in other dimensions
and uh and by by relegating us to
simply this 3d experience then like
without that
without that dna plugged in like
we now kind of feel
we don't understand why like why we're
here like yeah
like we're kind of just in the dark like
they rendered us yeah impotent in some
kind yeah i don't doubt a version like
that at all i mean i'm not a geneticist
obviously anymore
but um
but yeah i mean i think like the way it
looks like to me barbara marciniak she
was the earth the way it looks like to
me is that something came here and
tampered with dna and all the chimeras
and all the weird [ __ ] you see on
pyramid walls is like half man half bull
and all this weird [ __ ] um even when you
look at the ancient sumerian texts it
talks a lot about those who from heaven
to earth came and you know they created
a slave species and so there's nephilim
the nephilim was part yes the giants of
the bible all that kind of stuff you
know because the the the the fallen
angels took women for wives and had give
birth to giants i mean there's a whole
series of stories and color that we can
paint with that someone [ __ ] with our
dna and i and i tend to think like
that there's something that's been
cyclical on earth where civilizations
rise and fall in these tower of babel
type moments where they will be as gods
strike them down change their languages
and all this weird [ __ ] i i really
believe there's truth to all that that
as soon as we let off a nuclear weapon
boom they show up again wow we were you
know we put all these kids in a zoo and
now they're building bombs we got a [ __ ]
we got a figure to sit out so i think
what i've learned is that
all the secrecy around ufos
was for good reason because we didn't
know what it was then we thought it was
aliens and we realized holy [ __ ] they're
not aliens or something else and then
we're like what do we do we need to
study this understand this we need to
build a
weaponry or something on a way to push
back we got to do something but it might
take like 70 years
and then like 70 years later i'm like
sitting there like
hey i got an idea let's talk about this
and some of the people are like it's
time to talk about it others were like
it's not time but um it's nature so we
gotta kind of confront it regardless but
it's very real it's insanely bigger than
you think it is it's not just a few
things in the sky it's
very very big i got brought over to
italy some dudes with italian
intelligence and vatican and u.n they
were all there when the military base
had these briefings and they showed me a
map
of the mediterranean and what was
happening was on the coast of sicily
all these like apartments were like
catching on fire
like a microwave boom some books boom
like the [ __ ] couch boom and so the
government came in and they're like what
the [ __ ] is going on here so they
quarantine the area get everyone to
leave and they're going why are things
catching on fire they detected they
detected these
um energy beams energy weapons or
something that were coming off of the
way out in the ocean in the
mediterranean
so
this dude gets uh he he was a colonel at
the time and he was in charge oh what
they looked out and saw were ufos were
out in the ocean [ __ ] around so the
head of the ufo program and the head of
the italian navy seals get on an
unmarked civilian helicopter and just
fly out to go see what's going on out
there
as they're flying a ufo pops out of the
ocean and shoots their [ __ ]
helicopter down
i have the documents on the italian
intelligence letterhead i talked to the
dude the two dudes i was in the meeting
with that were on the [ __ ] helicopter
i have pictures of the helicopter being
chased by the ufo and all the damage
that was done to it with some type of
microwave weapon or something
and what they found out was
that there were airplanes and other
helicopters kind of in the area but the
ufo knew that those dudes were looking
for him it's like they can read their
minds it's like we have drones that fly
around and listen to people's like cell
phones and [ __ ]
they do it with thought
you know imagine in advance sorry we
don't need to listen to their phone i'll
just [ __ ] point my dish
at stevo and i can hear as well it's
[ __ ] he's thinking of some weird [ __ ]
you know like right right shoot him down
you know so um it's it's just absolutely
wild so the map they showed me of the
mediterranean
they go these are all the hot spots of
what's happening with ufos just recently
and there was hundreds of marks hundreds
all over the ocean there
just things happening everywhere
every day it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
there's a big base under puerto rico off
the i think they're i think they're
probably i would imagine and all over
the place in our oceans yeah yeah i mean
there's so much i want to ask you
because it's so fascinating for me um
maybe you can help me find this
documentary i was i went down the rabbit
hole on youtube 10 years ago and it was
the man who spoke 100 language
and he worked
he visited the white house during the
eisenhower and he was like well liked
and everybody liked them and then i
couldn't find this documentary anywhere
so i'm like is this a figment of my
imagination or there's these stories
valiant thor in the um yeah the stranger
at the pentagon yeah yeah where
a dude shows up that's super smart says
he's from venus and he's hanging out in
the pentagon of these things and he's
giving us all this knowledge um
two things
three things one it's either true or
it's not two
he's lying he's not from venus or
something or three um you know he's
maybe he's from here or you know in and
he's lying from where he's from
um but the idea of
i'll say it this way i personally in my
own opinion subscribe
to
face-to-face interactions and technology
transfer and all that kind of stuff i
believe there's a possibility for that
to have existed
i say this because i have pieces of
wreckage from the 40s under a defense
contract with the government right now
and you can look that up if you look up
tom delong army
material you'll see all the articles
it's the first
it's the first time in history the us
government's talking about doing
you know a defense contract on purported
ufo material we've had that for a couple
years being studied in like crazy ways i
can't talk much about it but
if i have that i would imagine that some
of the governments on the world have a
lot more than i got you know and they're
not we're not saying that this is real
we're saying it's highly
um
it's it's highly anomalous it's the
engineering on this one piece looks to
be [ __ ] crazy and and that is still
still looking to be the the case here
after having this contract for the past
couple years they've been studying it so
there's nothing to this we would have
lost that contract like two months into
it you know so we'll see where it goes
and all that kind of stuff but if if i
have a piece and it's looking to be
pretty gnarly then i'm assuming that
other places have some way bigger pieces
so if that's the case then
then then it's easy for me to say well
then i feel
there's a high likelihood that there's
been encounters there's been
conversations there's been interactions
there's been landings there's been
technology transfers there's been
something um but i i do not know like i
can sit there and say yeah they brought
me in and i hung out with this dude that
said he's from venus you know that's
never gonna happen but um i just think
it's highly likely that something like
that exists
i as a lay person i think that my
takeaway
so far my my my
general sense
is that
ufos this whole thing
is a good thing because they don't want
us to blow up the world with nuclear
weapons well people want that to be the
case
i wish that was the case the evidence
doesn't suggest that's the case
i think ufos don't want us getting too
powerful i don't think that
because you go and just look at the
nuclear weapons you got to go back
thousands of years and go
in the earliest documentations of
mankind's encounters with the spirit
world
what was happening just macro brush
stroke okay and it's always about
managing suppressing consciousness
confusing our belief systems
and and keeping us separate from one
another and not letting us get powerful
you know there was another component
of the uh
the that pleiadian
theory which was that
and by the way i think it was like 300
000 years ago they said that they
unplugged the dna
there was another
piece to it which was that the the
entities that unplugged us
were
nourished
not by physical matter but nourished by
emotion yeah they actually uh were there
there's their sustenance was and and
specifically fear yes so fear
feeds
this this entity that that controls us
and so it's in their interest that we be
afraid yeah there's uh i was just
reading a book in a song ago where
there's a ufologist that got invited to
this seance thing where they were
channeling and interacting with this
like [ __ ] demon or something and
they're all sitting in a circle and then
they put the one guy in the middle and
he starts channeling and gets possessed
by this energy and the first entity's
like hey we're
where are we are these entities that are
adjacent to you in another timeline
and all this stuff and we can't feel
emotion and but we need you to host to
help us feel emotion but then [ __ ]
starts going horribly wrong paranormal
stuff the temperature drops all this
weird [ __ ] and everyone in that room
except for two people died within six
months and weird occurrences
and this guy was one of the guys that
didn't and what i find is really strange
about that is that when you
you know
having a host consciousness in your body
um and then
looking at some of the visitations and
what some of the evidence looks like it
looks like there's
there's beings that don't have
it's like maybe they don't have souls
maybe they're ai maybe they're a
different life form like an insect that
grew it's like well i'm not scared of a
goldfish so i leave earth i come back 10
billion years later that goldfish is a
t-rex and you're like whoa and then you
leave earth and then go that t-rex is
now like a lot shorter and it's like a
[ __ ] lizard dude that's telepathic
and building spaceships and you're like
it took like 20 billion years but it
happened because no one [ __ ] [ __ ]
with this planet you know right so you
can see how life just grows in a certain
direction so then you kind of wonder
well
if something grew for millions billions
of years that never had a consciousness
to begin with like a fly or something
and then
now it can kind of pop over laterally
and to our [ __ ] timeline it's going
to come on you like flies on dog [ __ ] oh
what is this huh what is this they're
just like looking at you right how scary
would that be in your bed and you got
these big bug-eyed insects they're like
what are you what is going on they start
cutting you open and they're like and
then all of a sudden you get scared like
that's an interesting energy they'll
feel that we can feel something you know
i can see that being the case where
emotion and feeling and love is like so
gnarly it's like they want to understand
it they want to have it but what if they
figure out like hypothetically what if
they figure out that um
that we're immortal
that our soul is part of something
greater and bigger right and we might
die and have a painful life but we learn
a lot of lessons and we might
reincarnate
you know to learn more or whatever and
they're sitting here going if we die we
have nothing
they're all we want that
and then what if we have those
interactions we start writing books in
the bible it says satan wants your soul
demons want your soul
you know it starts to all make a little
bit more sense right
it's a crazy bigger picture it's just me
briffing i'm not saying anything just
riffing so is that what they're doing
when they're like abducting people like
that the fire in the sky movie the
evidence
from people that have had interactions
for
[ __ ] thousands of years including the
past hundred years on all different
types of people ethnicities and
different [ __ ] cultures and different
continents
tends to point the same direction that
they're very interested in our
consciousness and our soul and they're
very interested in making sure that we
don't know they're here and that we
don't all align and understand who we
are what we're capable of
and like
because the truth is is once we
understand what consciousness is
and it's not jesus
you know once we understand that then we
start realizing you can move objects
with your mind you can hear people's
thoughts telepathically like if you meet
a chick and she wants to [ __ ] you that's
telepathy but it's such a primal
animal frequency you can feel it wow
this chicks like game right but if you
see that same chick and she's sad you
don't really feel that just instantly
you might kind of it's just not as
strong and easy as like a sexual kind of
frequency or something well that's all
telepathy and i think like once we learn
like what we're capable of and how to
use how to how to
transduce our environment i mean because
they're already doing this dude i just
downloaded a [ __ ] ton of documents
two days ago
from the mcdonald douglas corporation
aircrafts in the 50s
and it's all from
the tangential programs of the main ufo
program describing
how to merge your conscious and
subconscious together to move objects
with your mind and how that's going to
relate to the propulsion system
it's [ __ ] crazy your thought will
move the craft
so that's what bob lazar was talking
about how they're building the the
crafts was ours the reason we all know
about area 51 is because of him my
company to the stars put out his
autobiography it's called dreamland it's
rad yeah it's totally rad yeah and i i i
believe them i think it's telling the
truth when when you say that they're
worried
they're they're
the ufos don't want
humans to become too powerful
like
i think there's more than one too like i
don't think there's like
one group here so it's hard we all agree
it's like it's like when we it would be
more better to say ufos it's probably
better to say you know competing
intelligences because who knows it's
like you're in the ocean you see a
dolphin so you're like okay so this
place is full of dolphins and you see a
[ __ ] jellyfish you're like oh that's
weird you see a whale but then you see a
coke can and you're like
then you find the boat but you're still
not even thinking that the boat's from
land
you know so we don't know the universe
has all that you know fair point
i just think that like when i think of
humans becoming too powerful that's a
concept that i can kind of grasp when i
see the way
you know just consider the way we've
paved over the world we've like you know
environmental destruction you know like
i feel like
we've kind of become too powerful yeah i
think you know i don't think anyone can
disagree that like we're like destroying
the planet and destroying each other
which is like we have the technology to
do that
before we have the spirituality to not
do that you know right it's like we this
idea that
you know but this is the other thing the
universe to me
it looks to be what we call duality
where every particle has a counterpart
so every every atom has like a negative
and a positive particle the realm of the
relative and well you have light you
have dark you have opposites you have
the past in the future all everything is
like duality
so even when you look at earth there's a
dual system you have democracy
and freedom and free will and then you
have authoritarianism and controlled and
absence of love absence of individuality
and it's competing systems but i think
it's representative of the universe we
live in you got to think of the yin and
the yang symbol that's like very real
that's to do that's duality every
ancient religion talked of duality we
have heaven and hell the mayans had the
two-faced god or whatever the gnostics
have the exact same thing where you have
you know varying versions of
a supreme loving kind of realm and
something that's opposite that's entropy
and falling apart and i think that like
i think we're just stuck in the middle
of it you know are you familiar with
neil donald walsh
um no but i am familiar with uh neil
armstrong is he the same question
neil donald walsh wrote a series of
books called conversations with god i've
heard of that and i love that we both
love that is rat yeah okay it's super
rad and the concept there is that
um
that
the universe
god
is uh
absolute love pure love but
being absolute
just one thing you know we we're all
familiar with the concept of oneness you
know
we are all one but as just one thing
being absolute love it has no uh
ability to have experience because it's
only one thing it needs another
something to relate to a reflection of
itself right
so
so the the actual universe this is the
theory the universe is
an exercise in that absolute
love
experiencing itself where it divides
itself into a multitude of parts so that
each part can relate to the other part
and only and in that move
you go from the absolute realm to the
relative realm yeah and relative meaning
that you can't have
nothing can be cold unless you have hot
yup you know nothing can always happen
unless you have down yeah and so it's
all you know that division of the
absolute creates the ability for there
to be experience yep i totally subscribe
to that and thus we are all and and all
of creation is an exercise in god
experiencing itself totally and i think
like you know there's a guy wrote a
fascinating book called my big toe the
theory of everything is this like
crazy physicist trying to figure out how
it all works and he said the same thing
if there is like one source unified mind
the only way for it to evolve because
you devolve or evolve is to break off
pieces of itself and learn lessons
without knowing the answer like we're in
a quiz and if someone goes dude you can
die you're immortal you're fine you're
like oh [ __ ] then [ __ ] it i'll jump in
front of a train you know
no nothing matters but if you don't know
that then you'll act differently and
you'll learn differently and you'll
you'll have compassion and all these
different things and i and and then
source can grow and i think the but the
difference here is what's interesting is
the way i the way i see it in my mind
it's imagine you have like the shoe box
of light and that's like the [ __ ]
love you know everything's combined and
we're all one and then you have a shoe
box of pitch blackness that's the
absence of that and then you shove them
together
and all the light goes dark but all
you're left with these little specks of
light in the darkness those are like
stars
and those are spitting out and those
grow out onto planets and create these
little life forms that experience thing
and everything's existing in the same
place
and that's where you get kind of the
geometries the the you know this they
show you those shapes where the
staircases spiral down or plants grow in
a spiral it's like holographic like like
everything is existing within the same
location going into itself almost like
um
a hologram if you look at it and i see a
picture of you in 3d and i break it into
like a bunch of glass pieces every piece
contains you did you know that i can
take a broken piece of that hologram and
look down and i'll see your whole body
even though it's just like your ear you
know it's like that's that's just every
hologram that we [ __ ] around with and we
print with lasers and do something funny
are cool with it but that's kind of how
the universe is it's like everything's
within itself yeah somebody uh
just said one line that i just grabbed
onto so much when
we are all eyes in the same head
that's pretty interesting
we are all
dicks in the same independence
same pretty much the exact same you know
it's funny did you ever think that you'd
be here go and talk about like
conversations with god and [ __ ] like
what happened to you i i mean like it's
something that began
for me like before sobriety and [ __ ] you
know like i did drugs to the point where
uh
where
the compartments
between
different things yeah eroded yeah and
when and i really really uh
latch on it resonates with me what you
said about the the frequencies high
frequency is love and then down here it
gets darker and you know and um
for me drugs became
super spiritual
like um
where
i had uh
hallucinations i was hearing voices i
was like seeing like odd like like i was
seeing people walk around who were never
physically there i was hearing voices i
was it was just all of this other
worldly [ __ ] and and i was so
[ __ ]
like blown away by it i loved it so much
i just kept piling more drugs into my
body to keep it happening yeah this was
my spiritual connection and um
the thing
about that it as it was as fascinating
as it was as much as i loved it like it
i recognized that that was a dangerous
approach to spirituality because the the
dr i believe the drugs i was doing
eroded
the the barriers between other uh yeah
yeah it's like it's opening up the dial
and you're getting flooded with so much
but it's but by doing it that way you're
letting in like just all [ __ ] who
knows what's coming in demon ass [ __ ]
yeah you're tuned into a radio station
and you said let's just listen to all
the stations at once
you know what drug
did it the most for you what drug does
all the barriers the most or was it like
it was three days of cocaine and and and
huffing like
nitrous oxide that's gnarly what if he
said estrogen he's i used to do so much
estrogen it was insane dude that's heavy
yeah i mean people do it would always be
three days of cocaine and i would
basically do to do cocaine for three
days and i'd be doing nitrous inhaling
nitrous oxide the whole time
and and and the more sleep deprived
yeah yeah they should have studied you
in the government because i think
they're like they got all into lsd and
all that [ __ ] in the 60s i used to be
the stevo kid like we got to see what
the [ __ ] it's all he knows everything
about drugs let's [ __ ] figure it out
but were you like doing drugs like all
right day two i got one more day and
then i can start seeing some [ __ ] or it
just happened and i think day three his
body shutting down and he's probably
time to stop i don't know if it was a
plan yeah
like it
generally day three was was where i was
uh
navy seal hell week except they're not
on cook but there's
sleep deprivation and stuff i i was on
my final stretch at that point but you
know like
compared to now
and i've got like when you were talking
about how we're uh we're not reactive
but we're we're inducers we're inducers
we're we're creating our we're literally
this is quantum physics like we don't
know this but the scientists know this
well i i i'm so so struck by that
because um
for uh
for
924
consecutive days i've maintained an
average of over 40 minutes of meditation
every single day that's [ __ ] great
dude everyone is terrified to stop well
let me tell you something that's really
dope so
um my friend mark from blink
uh got cancer and he's cool now like he
got it all like it's all taken care of
but when it happened
i was like i know that energy healing
works and so i called up my partner from
cia and he goes dude he's all it's very
real he's all whenever we have people
within the agency that gets sick we send
them to this one guy
and what they do
is there's a really cool story there's a
phd that sells to do those energy
healing you know and he's like
well i want to test you in the lab and
so they set up all these experiments all
these mice gave all the mice cancer and
the day before something that the energy
healer is like i can't do it and so
they're just going to shut the thing
down but then one of the the clint the
the technicians told the phd
guy she's like well why don't you just
do it you know what he was doing he goes
i can't do it he's like special no he
just puts his hands near something and
focuses in tension and whatever just do
it you already spent the money you
already got the [ __ ] mice that are
sick well all of these mice
were 100 not 90 not 70
100
going to die on day 27 because they gave
him that type of cancer they do it all
time so he goes up there and he goes
okay spends a few hours each day hands
on the cage just intending all you do is
focus on destroying the tumors helping
healthy healthy healthy mice nothing's
happening it's like week two and there's
a [ __ ] nothing happening so he's
going to cancel she's not just keep
going just do the full [ __ ] 27 days
well like on day 20 21 the tumors start
exploding
starts healing all the mice they take
the blood out of the mice go to a
different cage put it in there but
[ __ ] heals those mice no another mice
can ever get that cancer again
they then do energy healing on a cotton
swab and they smell the cotton swab
across the country put that cotton swab
in with some ice it heals those [ __ ]
mice and what it's led to was a profound
discovery that consciousness again
is what dictates physical everything and
if you
meditate
or you pray
or you get on your knees and [ __ ]
focus on it doesn't matter when you shut
your mind down and open up bandwidth to
god source it doesn't physics doesn't
care if you think it's all odd jesus
consciousness just just
shut your mind down you can do anything
because you're a transducer of your
environment so you can heal [ __ ] you can
heal cancer you can walk on water like
jesus you can lay on a bed of nails you
can walk across fire you can levitate my
my partner physicist was dispatched by
the dod to the middle east to check out
these dudes that were meditating and
levitating like we see in cartoons you
know like ooh you know the snake comes
out and
that was happening
and they couldn't understand why because
it was consciousness
like so my point is is like we're so
powerful we don't even know it and i'm
not saying i know how to do all this
[ __ ] but i'm telling you it's like real
for sure i i'm terrified of ever missing
a meditation like i'd keep track of it
on an app
this is what you need i'm not saying i
know how to do this but you you're you
meditate like way more than i do and i
wish i did it like you but what the real
goal
is to meditate
while you're walking around
and that's like monk [ __ ] that's a jedi
my my deal is like mantra meditation so
like i'm just sitting still and and uh
yeah could you imagine if like right now
you're [ __ ] locked in
yeah i mean
you'd be like luke skywalker i'm telling
you
it's like jedi [ __ ] i mean i i really
subscribe to it here's something that
i've um
i i've said said a lot like um
we were talking about it this morning
you know like the most people's problem
is that they don't have a a goal
you can't
accomplish you can't accomplish
something without first identifying
what you want to accomplish because when
you have a purpose or a goal you are
creating that remember like if you don't
have one what are you creating like if
you're working towards something you're
envisioning it you're thinking about it
you're planning it you're making steps
to get there that is manifesting that
reality that's how it starts and if you
don't have that then it's kind of vacant
you know for sure and uh and and once
you've identified a goal
then
intelligence is is helpful for sort of
conceiving ways to to
you know accomplish it um
certainly uh talent is helpful you know
for like
but
nothing
comes [ __ ] close to enthusiasm
interesting enthusiasm is the engine
which drives the human experience like
it doesn't matter
it doesn't [ __ ] matter if i'm
talented or intelligent if i [ __ ]
have passion then i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm
gonna make it happen and then as i i i
related this you know this uh
many times and then just out of nowhere
somebody offered up on their own without
me even
they said uh
the the latin
root for the word enthusiasm
is en theos which means with god wow
it's dope so love that it's cool yeah so
when you're when you're when you're
[ __ ] on fire for something you're
with god you're with god you're doing
god's work doing the lord's work and i
love that too man so when you're horny
and you're really passionately horny
doing i'm with god yeah i mean uh i you
know i whenever um
whenever people historically and you
know would ask me advice on something
you know like
how do i
do this well you know my first advice is
whatever it is you want to
do or get good at
start doing it don't wait for for
someone to pick you don't wait for this
starts to line up
you know start doing it with one caveat
make sure that that you're not uh that
you're starting that you're learning the
right way because because we can
like get all on one and then start like
learning bad habits you don't want to
learn bad habits that you're going to
have to unlearn so maybe find a mentor
somebody who's
done it before for somebody who can make
sure you're on the right track like
notice right yeah fine find a way to
make sure that you're learning the
correct way but waste no time start
doing it and then i would say
it doesn't matter what you want
to accomplish it simply matters how
[ __ ] bad you want it oh i so agree
with that that enthusiasm and um
and i think that that for for me this is
where my meditation comes in
is that uh
is is that
it
if i feel
that it it plugs me in
i i plug into this [ __ ] source
whatever
where like i bring
i've got the intent the intention you
know i've got the intention i've got the
[ __ ] enthusiasm and i just plug into
the the the source
which i really
i
[ __ ] believe that the universe
conspires in my favor because i meditate
no it does dude trust me you're not the
first person that that that works for
like i know people that are so hardcore
on that because it literally dictates
everything else is calm clear present
and things just start happening for you
because you connect and you let all the
[ __ ] go and you just get like this
the juice of fuel that you need i mean
you're a consciousness
you know you're a being that's living
through consciousness so
why would you not stop to reful feel
that tank you know i i totally subscribe
to it and i think it's really awesome
that you do it you know what thanks man
yeah when we were when i first met mario
our buddy mario he said he grew up with
you and and you know new mexico and he
said you just always go to people like
hi my name is steve i'm gonna be on tv
one day
i love that
and and the i think the difference
between you and somebody else is like
uh
correct me if i'm wrong but was there
any doubt that one day you'd be on tv
or did you know i i was uh
pretty
cause that's enthusiasm yeah i do
tireless enthusiasm um i
believed that one of two things was
gonna happen i was gonna either make my
mark and become famous in life or uh all
of the
the video that i was
you know recording and effectively
stepping into a bottle would be
discovered after i died
yeah one of the two but you will make it
cool yeah
that was everything that i was about i
was like oh dude this footage lives
forever like this footage so let me make
sure this footage is [ __ ] bad i gotta
do i gotta tell you when you did the
[ __ ]
wild boy with wild voices yeah that
thing with the hot dogs and the lions
was the gnarliest thing i think i've
ever seen in my life
that like because you just remember you
falling from the hammock into the lions
right the [ __ ] were you guys thinking so
heavy yeah it was heavy the uh the first
trip we took to
to film the
pilot for for wild boys we went out to
south africa because that's where they
had the great white sharks we wanted to
jump off the boat and next to the great
white shark
that was like the main reason why we did
the pilot in south africa we also
we also brought a zebra suit two-man
zebra suit
for us to go on safari we wanted to get
a shot with the lion
they told us
like that's not how it [ __ ] works you
don't [ __ ] you know like like you
don't [ __ ] around with lines like that
nobody we brought the suit out there
we brought the zebra scene out there to
do that they're like no no no so like we
would get in the zebra suit on safari
like when there was like different
scenes going on but never with an actual
line around because no one would let us
do that so we had all this footage and
then we're like whoa [ __ ] what are we
gonna do and they had this company
called hollywood animals in california
and so we got the final shot the final
bit was it was shot in uh
in california with one of these [ __ ]
so funny so yeah and so everything that
the where were with lions like like up
in the tree with the lions you know like
that's hollywood animals it's still
scary
dude i don't give a [ __ ] that's a lion
dude was it not a lion all of a sudden
that's still alive
gnarly
my my closest call with death was was a
lion climbing up a tree and getting all
on me and like moments before
i uh
had made some snarky comment about
siegfried and roy it was like oh
that's like yeah yeah you got you got it
you got a lesson i like that yeah dude i
got a major life lesson but dude like
among the most fascinating [ __ ]
conversations we've ever had oh good dan
i appreciate that yeah yeah sure i i
appreciate both you guys
i gotta jump back in the studio um yeah
we appreciate you yeah thank you so much
and um yeah
like anything i'm going to steal this
from mike tyson every time
there's millions of people
what do you want to say to them
uh what i want to say um what do i want
to say to all these people i want to say
that
a lot of people don't understand me or
my thinking or what i'm doing a lot of
people hear the ufo thing i don't really
get it
my company to the stars has really
gotten itself in a really cool position
to help you understand all these things
uh that are a lot to digest for people
and it still comes from this kind of
rebellious punk rock skateboarder youth
that i've always been which was like
kind of do my own thing you know and i
chase things that i think can make the
world cooler or better or funnier or
happier and
i really believe that i'm kind of in the
in the epicenter of a lot of really cool
things but you know
that are going to really influence the
world but the the movies and all the
things i'm making are really a direct
result
of
the people i work with the things that
i've figured out the things that we're
doing with the government and like
really trying to get people to
understand that you're powerful you're
[ __ ] awesome and you can make life
what you want it you just gotta
understand how it works and that's kind
of the realm that i think humans are in
right now we're going to start to learn
because it's been secret for song
what we're capable of and how this all
works and it's going to profoundly
change the human experience in a way
that you're already discovering you i
don't know man you're just not doing it
yeah questionable that's questionable
all right thank you guys so much yeah
man my cat brother that was great
all right kids
and there you have it
that's one cool dude
i mean one crazy dude but one cool dude
i uh
really really like him and you know i'm
gonna say i really really like you for
sticking around to the end of the
podcast my street team people that that
really show me that love and who i
appreciate so much and let me what can i
tell you today i just started signing
the pages which are bound into the book
my new book
it's called a hard kick in the nuts what
i learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions it's a book of wisdom man i
got a quotes from knoxville and dana
white on the cover waiting on one from
whitney cummings
and um
i think i can safely say the only way
that you can possibly get a
autographed
copy of the hardcover version is by
pre-ordering it and why is that is
because
man it's all about the pre-orders like
on the first week when the book comes
out it uh like automatically all of the
pre-orders count toward that first week
and that's gonna have all kinds of
bearing on where the book lands on the
new york times bestseller list and dude
this book is so ferociously good i'm
dying for it to be number one on the new
york times bestseller list and so please
help me get there i promise you this
book will not let you down it's juicier
than hell
and if you go
to just to my website stevo.com right at
the top of the website it's click here
for the pre-order and you got to pick
the right distributor to get the signed
ones but yeah i'm up there signing these
pages like crazy it's the legit
dickograph it's the epic book and please
pre-order it at uh stevo.com a hard kick
in the nuts i love you thank you so much